well i don't have to tell you this  affordable housing is a huge need in  southern nevada well a new apartment  complex coming to north las vegas could  help today crews broke ground on lake  mead west apartments on lake mead near  texas station the gated complex will  have 156 units a dog park and a barbecue  it is directly across the street from  detweller elementary school  affordable just means that there is an  opportunity for somebody to pay a little  less in rent it does not mean that  the quality of construction is low  somehow  the project is a public private  partnership with the city of north las  vegas nevada housing division four side  companies and a private investor called  redstone